It comes to food allergies, IgG in particularly, being they can change so frequently how often would
you recommend testing. I feel like it shows the state of your gut at that moment but can change
often. Well, I agree for a large part, IgG, IgA, food allergies, food sensitivity testing can
be a little fickle. So, but it does give us a good picture of what could be causing inflammation
at that time. Now, it depends on the food, the food itself. Some studies have been done with
gliann and IgG antibodies. It shows that they could last forever and cause problems forever,
even if the person is on a complete very strict gluten-free diet. But then other foods can dissipate
quite quickly. So, when we do like a Cyrex 10 which tests for IgA and IgG antibodies and
separates cooked from raw foods which I think gets more specificity in your testing, I recommend
testing retested at three months. If that's the person's made concern that we're dealing with trying
to call noly inflammation of the gut. So, yeah, and again, when you do a food sensitivity test,
it's not so much I'm looking for what I can eat and can't eat. Yes, there's that piece of that.
Okay, I have high antibodies to whatever. So, I'm going to keep that out of my diet. But it's giving
you an indication of the amount of inflammation that's in your gut. If you come back with a food
sensitivity test and you have so many things in the yellow and red and it's high antibodies to
soak to a lot of different things, it really tells you that there's a lot of inflammation that's
going on in your. You do want to investigate whether you have paracellular or transcellular
forms of leaky got a differentiation between that and you do want to differentiate whether you have
antibodies to lipopolysaccharides as well because that's going to tell you other indications of
the severity of the gut permeability that's going on. So, a Cyrex array 2 could be beneficial to tell
you those things. That tells you the severity that you need to really deal with this issue too.
So, again, if you're doing a food sensitivity test and all you're doing with that data is changing
your diet, you're really missing the whole point. You're doing a food sensitivity test to change
the diet but then to decrease the inflammation and to start healing the gut. So, you have to be working on
things that are going to heal your gut along with that or all you're going to do is you're going to
do another test in three months and you're going to have different things that are going to be out of
balance. Oh, now it's not this but it's this that was in the green before. How come what's a deal?
Do you have anything to actually fix the problem? With most leaky gut issues, I think I've described
this before in other holistic health hours you could have. Would you describe most leaky gut issues?
It's typically described when the gut cells separate from one another and you don't have those
tight junctions. That's called pericelular permeability. It can get worse than that. You can actually
have transcellular permeability where the cells themselves are so damaged that things are going
through the cells. And then it testing if you have antibodies to lipopolysaccharides that gives you
other clues. Do you know that you have gram negative bacteria issues as well? Because if you have
antibodies to lipopolysaccharides then you already know that you have damage to the blood brain barrier
as well. So healing those barriers is a key to the really getting better.